Земельна реформа - нині одна з найгучніших і найсуперечливіших тем в українському суспільстві.
Під час виступу у парламенті аграрії кричали Вам "ганьба"
Чи були Ви  готові до того, що ця реформа буде такою непопулярною?
Не всі кричали. Половина приблизно.
Там був такий момент, його дуже добре видно на камерах,
коли спікер, хто проти реформи, запитав:
"Встаньте ті , хто проти". І половина залу десь встало.
Половина - за, половина - проти. Це добре. Це демократія.
Різні точки зору. Я був готовий.
Я навіть думав, що буде набагато гірше.
Насправді люди готові до реформи, розуміють,
особливо ті, хто працюють на землі, що...
так продовжувати не можна.
Все ж такі різні опитування показують, що не половина людей,
а можливо, більше людей в Україні проти продажу землі.
Чим ви це пояснюєте?
Залежитьвід того, як ставиться питання.
Не йдеться зараз про продаж землі. Йдеться про те,
що ті , хто вже є власником - приватна власність у людини,
щоб їм дозволили продавати цю землю.
Друга про те, щоб державну землю передати в громаду,
щоб громади розпоряджалися землею.
Не Держгеокадастр, як сьогодні відбувається,
не державні підприємства, де, ми знаємо, є багато корупції.
Адля того, щоб  землею розпоряджався саме українець.
А, звичайно, ті, хто заробляє сьогодні
десятки чи сотні  мільйонів на тому, що є можливість
непрозоро використовувати державну землю на свою користь,
ті люди, до речі, вони є в парламенті, ті люди проти.
Наведіть, будь ласка, три переконливі аргументи
на користь відкриття ринку землі.
Перший, найголовнішій для мене - це те,
що нам потрібні "довгі і дешеві гроші".
Вони нам потрібні, щоб агрогалузь і сільське господарство розвивалася.
іне тільки розвивалися через те, що вирощують зерно,
але і через переробку, через обробку.
Тобто додана вартість має бути збільшена. Для цього потрібне кредитування.
Для кредитування потрібний власник.
Ніхто не буде кредитувати по-справжньому фермера,
який трохи, вибачте, "на птичих правах"
має в оренді шалені активи,  і є ризик, що хтось цю оренду скасує.
Друга причина, ті сім мільйонів власників мають право
отримувати достойну винагороду, більшу цю оренду,
або більшу суму при продажу, це друга причина.
І третя причина.Я думаю, що люди, які хочуть відкрити
відкрити свою,може, маленьку ферму, а можетрошки більше,
мають можливість купити землю.
Але є ще і четверте.
Це податки.
Це коли люди беруть,
не оформлюють навіть землю, не платять податки.
Ці податки не попадають в село,
і насправді не  дозволяють селу розвиватися.
Як Ви можете прокоментувати поширені побоювання,
що в разі відкриття ринку землі...
українська земля опиниться або у руках олігархів,
або у власності великих корпорацій, або навіть у росіян?
У росіян  вже було.
Був холдинг, який через оренду контролював більше 200 000 гектарів.
Тому насправді зараз легше іноземцям контролювати,
не тільки іноземцям, а і олігархам, а інколи просто бандитам
контролювати землю через оренду.
Для цього і робиться детінізація ринку землі.
Насправдія не називав би реформу "реформою ринку землі".
Я би називав реформу"детінізацією ринку землі".
Є інша проблема, про яку менше знають,
яка схожа на олігархічну.
Вона просто по-іншому виглядає.
Це те, що я називаю або інші люди називають "чорні холдинги".
Це є земля, яка нібито нічия,
ніби її немає на картах. Але вона є, але в кадастрі немає,
чи вона там є,  але її не можна обробляти
або невідомо кому належить. І там щось собі росте.
І це збирається кимось ...
і вивозиться. І хтось на цьому заробляє…
Чи багато таких земель, які нікому не належать?
Таких земель багато.  Вони, наприклад, ми знаємо, що
багато на державних підприємствах є.
За останні 4-5 років 314 кримінальних справ
саме по таких речах.
І сотні тисяч гектарів, які офіційно не обробляються.
Що ви в такому випадку очікуєте від інвентаризації земель?
Ми будемо знати, скільки є державної землі,
і скільки її не стало.
Півтора мільйона було на кінець 90-их років
за документами в держпідприємствах тільки.
А зараз, за результатами інвентаризації, очікуємо,
що буде максимум  600-700 тисяч.
Десь половину землі вивели різними схемами.
Якщо Україна втратила половину земель сільгосппризначення,
то це в грошах скільки?
Ось, 700000 давайте помножимо, якщо воно буде по 2000 доларів,
це 1,5 млрд доларів. 1,4 млрд. доларів.
А якщо цю землю насправді здавали не як агро,
а переоформлювали на якісь розбудови,
приміром, під Києвом, де найбільш дорожча земля,
то взагалі може бути кілька мільярдів доларів.
Хтось заробив близький до влади.
Чи задоволені Ви, як працює Держгеокадастр?
Чи відкриті взагалі всі дані?
Чи можуть українці побачити свої землі, чітко, де це на мапі?
Ми, до речі, відсторонюємо все керівництво Геокадастру
і будемо проводити розслідування всередині,
що там насправді відбувалося.
Багато даних вже відкриті,
сам Геокадастр відкритий, мапа відкрита.
Конкретні координати не завжди чіткі.
Є і випадки, коли не виносилося в натурі.
І є випадки, є випадки  просто корупції,
коли земля насправді була зареєстрована в кадастрі,
але робили вигляд, що не було .
Ми зробили мапу на основі супутникових даних і штучного інтелекту.
Там можна побачити землю, сільськогосподарську землю,
де щось росте, але воно не є в кадастрі.
Там, де не зареєстровано, вже можемо і будемо відправляти інспекції,
які перевіряють чому ті ділянки не є зареєстрованими.
Мінекономіки на чолі з Вами віднедавна відповідальне за ринок праці.
За офіційними даними міністерства, в Україні 1,5 млн. безробітних.
Як ви збираєтеся скоротити цей показник?
Це дуже великий показник і це, знаєте, такий парадокс.
У нас є по суті два ринка праці.
Один ринок - там, де багато вакансій і високі зарплати
і дуже мало людей, кваліфікованих саме для тих робіт.
А другий ринок, праці де  мало вакансій,
маленькі зарплати і дуже багато людей.
Наприклад, за нашими дослідженнями, одночасно
найбільша велика кількість людей, які  шукають роботу,
вони в сільському господарстві.
І одночасно там найбільш велика  потреба, але різні типи професій.
Висококваліфіковані люди, які можуть десь навіть програмувати,
чи працювати з дронами, з іншими технологіями - аналітичними.
А люди, які шукають роботу в агро, вони не мають таких навичок.
Наше завдання - перенести людей з цього ринку
на той, де є робота, і де більше платять.
Це за рахунок освіти професійної для дорослих,
і це потрібно розвивати.
Коли українцям очікувати більш-менш прийнятні кредити,
які хоч якось наближаються до ставок країн ЄС?
Для того, щоб ставка була низька на кредит, потрібні  три речі.
Перше, щоб облікова ставка НБУ була низька.
Друге - щоб самі банки були готові конкурувати за клієнта.
І третє - щоб клієнт міг показати свою насправді
свою історію, якщо це бізнес, то повністю свою "білу історію".
І відсотки потроху починають зменшуватися.
Ми бачимо, що НБУ почав знижувати відсоткову ставку свою облікову
За їх прогнозом, вона буде десь 9% на кінець наступного року.
Буде стабільність, то ставки, думаю,  досить швидко почнуть  знижуватися.
Якщо облікова ставка 9%,  а через рік вже 8%,
банки там почнуть заробляти, ну, + 2% +3%,
то 10, 11, 12%,
це може  бути реальністю кінця наступного року.
Чи може бути наступного року в Україні курс
20 гривень за долар?
Навряд чи… Думаю, це фантастика.
У нас тут є жарт: мовляв, фантастика на четвертому поверсі -
це  в міністерстві економіки.
Можемо таке фантазувати, але 20 - це маловірогідне.
Якщо до нас зайде дуже-дуже багато інвестицій….
А ми собі розглядаємо двасценарії - 3 і 6 мільярдів доларів
А якщо зайде 10 чи 20, то можливо такий курс і буде.
Але це знаєте, воно добре за рахунок інвестицій,
погано тим, кому треба високий курс.
Якщо курс зростає, зростає кількість гривень за долар,
то добре для експортерів.
Якщо падає - для імпортерів та населення.
Але відбуваються трохи інші речі:
курс падає, а ціни не змінюються. Що з цим робити?
Не зовсім так. Ціни завжди зростають в усіх країнах
Коли вони трохи зростають, то легше бізнесу розвиватися,
легше зарплату з часом піднімати, економіці легше розвиватися.
Для тих країн, що розвиваються, як наша,
5% - це нормальна інфляція.
Інфляція в нас дійсно падає.
На кінець року інфляція може бути 6% по прогнозах.
Минулого року вона була 10% - 9,8%.
Поза і позаминулого вона була 12%-13%.
А в 2015 вона була 40%.
Український  уряд готує до запуску програму "Повертайся і залишайся",
покликану заохотити до повернення  в країну
українців-заробітчан, які працюють за кордоном.
Ви самі певний час були мігрантом, мешкаючи в США.
Що б особисто Вас переконало повернутися в Україну?
Я повернувся, то, значить, щось переконало.
Переконали мене зміни, які відбулися в 14-му році.
Коли я  повірив в Україну.
А для усіх., я думаю...
Ні в 2014, ні в 2015, ні навіть зараз Ви би не змогли б отримати
якісь прийнятні умови для того, щоб відкрити бізнес?
Дійсно, кредит - це частина більше широкого бажання і  програми
держави створити умови, де ми показуємо,
що при цих умовах краще,  легше жити в Україні.
Конкретно в цьому випадку краще займатися своїм бізнесом  і створити свій бізнес.
Там  є 5, 7 і 9 % - три групи людей.
5% для тих, хто створює два додаткові робочі місця.
7% для тих, хто не створює, але має маленький обсяг.
І 9% для тих, хто має вже більшу компанію, більш на ногах стоїть.
Але більш широко, я думаю, що....
якщо  суспільство, держава буде показувати, що кожна людина важлива,
то люди будуть повертатися.
Решта українців, які не виїжджали за кордон, теж хочуть...
- Мають право.
- пільгові кредити!
Вони так саме мають право. Це програма є для всіх.
Вона для тих, хто в Україні, перш за все.
Тому, будь ласка, приходьте і використовуйте програму.
Приватизація держпідприємств, яка відбувається зараз.
Які Ви особисто бачити в цьому ризики?
Можливо, вперше Україна виставила таку кількість підприємств…
Ризики є, але є і можливості.
Я особисто бачу, перш за все, можливості.
В тому, що ми нарешті кубло корупції якось
знищимо і приведемо справжніх власників  і інвесторів.
Ми через податки більше зберемо.
І у людей буде робота, і будуть інвестиції.
Ось я заїхав підприємство "Комунар". До речі, назва.
Це підприємство, яке за радянських часів
мало 25 000 людей,
зараз там працює 2500.
Це підприємство, яке запускало "Союз" в космос,
робило всю електроніку.
І це підприємство сьогодні виробляє, скажімо так,
дуже просту продукцію.
Добре, що виробляють.
Але вони виробляють якісь лічильники для води тощо.
На це дуже боляче дивитися, що сталося з нашою промисловістю.
Нам потрібно щось міняти
Ми не можемо залишити все, як є.
Є ризики, що під час приватизації будуть усілякі оборудки вскриватися.
Але настав час  їх викривати і з ними боротися.
2020 рік - рік подальшого падіння промисловості?
Сподіваюся, що ні.  У промисловості є кілька проблем зараз.
Одна зі структурних  проблем полягає в тому, що чомусь, невідомо чому,
в цьому році не достатньо гарно працюють бронетанкові  контракти на експорт.
Це за собою тягне кілька критичних заводів вниз.
Друга причина, що  "Укрзалізниця" не дала в цьому році
достатньо  контрактів нашій промисловості.
Є приклади,
коли  наші підприємства, можливо, справедливо, а, можливо, і ні,
програвали  на тендерах російським підприємствам для київського метрополітену.
Це вже не Укрзалізниця, а інший приклад
Є і макроекономічні чинники. Це більше до металургії.
Кон’юнктура ринків світових зараз сильно погіршується,
тому очікуємо в цілому  економічного зростання в Україні
але в металургії , думаю, будуть складнощі.
Україну називають піратським раєм.
Як привчити громадян України
виконувати закони про авторське право?
Це, до речі, таке саме болюче питання рівня дискримінації жінок
чи людей з обмеженими можливостями.
Ми звикли, що десь можна скопіювати відео піратське,
що можна програмісту софтвер просто скачати.
Тому наші програмісти пишуть не для нас,
а  для європейських, чи  американських компаній,
які там можуть захистити права на ці ідеї.
І потім нам назад продати своє. Це неправильно.
Нам потрібно виробити…  Це культурна штука.
Потрібна повага до ідей інших. Ідею не можна красти.
Ви ж розумієте рівень зарплат в Україні?
Не всі люди можуть дозволити собі  купити справжню ліцензійну програму?
Це курка і яйце.
Через те, що ми такі бідні, ми крадемо.
А через те, що ми крадемо в самих себе, ми є трохи бідними.
Ви сказали, що не треба навчатися по книжках.
Зараз можете сказати, що Ви мали на увазі?
Це є така тенденція, коли мої колонки чи лекції,
які були зроблені чи видані тоді, коли я був  викладачем,
вирізаються з контексту, потім їх намагаються розкрутити.
Якщо воно там не чіпляється, то воно вмирає.
А якщо чіпляє, то воно потім далі...
Зачепило, схоже?
Це святе в українській культурі читати книжки.
Всі читають книжки.
В мене бібліотеці 3000 книжок.
Моя колонка була педагогічна.
і про те, що обов’язково пам’ятати про кілька функцій,
які треба тренувати, коли навчаєшся.
Одна - це дійсно читати.
Але друга – це відтворювати цю інформацію.
А трете - ще застосовувати цю інформацію.
Якщо тільки займатися читанням, а не займатися другим та третім,
то тоді це неефективно.
Ви заявили, що Вам не вистачає
міністерської зарплати у 18000 гривень
і Ви вимушені жити на заощадження.
Надовго Вас вистачить?
Там, в мене будуть премії.
Разом з преміями це буде достойна зарплатня.
Я вам скажу, яка зарплата у професора в США.
Якщо людина тільки закінчила докторську і отримує свою
першу позицію,  то в гарному університеті
високого рівня це 100-150тисяч
інколи 200тисяч доларів на рік.
Тому дійсно заощадження в мене є.
Пенсійний фонд американський від роботи професором  в мене є.
Їх мені достатньо навіть зараз піти на пенсію.
Що тоді Вас мотивує працювати міністром в Україні?
Я би хотів, щоб середня зарплата була не 11 тисяч,
не 16, як планується, а хоча б 30 тисяч.
І я, як міністр економіки,  спробую зробити все,
аби економіка стала сильнішою,
а через це і зарплати зросли би.